I know that earlier this year you you
had your struggle with cancer and you're
doing really well right now I just
wanted to hear how are you feeling with
koban 19 going going around right now
and the importance of keeping your
health self healthy right now yeah I
mean it's it's so strange but even when
you say it's a bring up on this I had a
cancer journey back and fräulein kidney
cancer everybody I had surgery and I'm
feeling great with that
but even as you're talking about it like
I got a little goosebumps because it's
you know being immune compromised right
we got to be concerned too you know
elderly people and being compromised
people people with pre-existing
conditions as we've been talking about
as the pros been talking about I'm one
of them I'm really trying to be as
careful as I can because I know even
before cancer I had a new function
issues already which may or may not have
led to my cancer journey and now coming
out of it still I'm so glad to hear that
you were well and and your wife must be
doing so well because the honey-do list
must be getting real small lots of
targets put like this how's the list now
Cadman's you probably know things about
that - I'm sure you guys are kind of
going through it - I gotta get your
husband but man that list is growing
because anybody at home relate to this
like I am I am dusting off like light
fixtures I am I'm cleaning out sheds I
took down my Christmas lights Patricia
the world don't go anywhere
I'm sure you know you're itching as well
to get back to work and your show is
working on ways to bring your show back
into people's homes really soon right
yeah yeah like you have to basically
we're trying to do essentially we to
canvas do it everybody thank you so much
for joining us again for another week at
home with our family the odd thing is to
the name of the show's home and family
so it's like kind of what the show is
all about anyways so we're taking to do
it up a level if we're really at home
with our fifth
you